all right let's watch it hopefully I'm
not horribly wrong okay you have made
your prediction now it's time to find
out which block went higher the one
that's shot off center or the one that
shot right into the center of mass okay
we're just getting set for shooting
straight into the block any feeling
about this one Dave I think this is the
one I really do remove this block so now
the gun is actually firing into the
right side of the block so presumably
what imagines that the block will spin
anti-clockwise
[Applause]
[Music]
now check out the high-speed footage you
can clearly see that both blocks go to
the exact same height even though one is
rotating and that's a bit strange
because they were both hit by the same
type of bullet from the same rifle so
presumably it had the same kinetic
energy and they both go the same height
so they both have the same gravitational
potential energy but one is rotating and
so it has that additional rotational
energy so one block has more energy than
the other block I don't know if I'll buy
that dr. Miller yeah doctor talk to me
yeah I mean so you're telling me you
just created energy not necessarily
created okay so what are you thinking
there I am
potentially surprised wrong that's the
same height which is incredibly
confusing to me why is that confusing
because that doesn't where's that extra
energy coming from but the fact is that
one block clearly does have more energy
you think about them both at the top one
spinning ones not they basically have
identical gravitational energy but one
does have additional rotational energy
how is that possible and why is it
happening no explain it to me I don't
want to give you the answer right away
below it would you say that I don't that
means you don't know so if you can make
me a video response I would love that
or if you just want to post your idea in
the comments below that'd be great and I
will reveal the correct answer next week
so subscribe to the channel if you
haven't already and you'll find out in a
week's time after I have time to pour
over the footage you consult with very
smart man
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]